Akemi starts off this hour in North
Carolina
hiya kami how are you hi Dave how are
you thank you so much for taking my call
today sure what's up in your world I am
30 years old I'm married and combined me
and my husband have roughly three
hundred and twenty eight thousand
dollars with the student loan debt I
know a house is out of the question
good who's the doctor or lawyer
unbelievable neither one of us I'm a
clinician I'm a counselor at marriage
and family counselor and he does graphic
design and engineering but I just
graduated last year so I'm still was so
much student loan debt for those degree
fields well he's out of state so that's
where he got hit in the head he has one
and a hundred and sixty six thousand
dollars so he went to a different state
that's why has is so high when Alden
Chacon uh-huh and Liza's undergrad and
graduate combined
okay what's your household income
combined together we're let's see I make
forty five thousand a year he makes
about fifty five okay it's gonna be a
long slog getting it kiddo
it is I know I already have no hope I
want you to have hope but it's gonna be
a distant light over the horizon I mean
you got mathematical issues here with a
hundred grand towards three hundred
grand I mean if I do sixty a year out of
your hundred and put your own beans and
rice that into three hundred that's like
what in that five years yeah yeah you
got a tough five six years ahead of you
and that's if you really really dial it
back and know you don't need to buy a
house do you clean this mess up the
question right what I said in kids would
probably also be out of the question out
of the scenario you know but you won't
be able to quit work a stay home oh no
no I've never wanted to go I couldn't do
that okay I mean kids you can have kids
and and they're not that expensive then
I mean you know they eat what you eat
usually if you're smart once I get past
the
early stages anyway but kids don't break
you but you know you don't have an extra
30,000 bucks to save up and put down on
the house while you've got three hundred
and thirty-eight thousand dollars of
student loan debt making a hundred grand
yeah absolutely not
yeah we're in an apartment so we're
we're gonna I totally need to stay there
until we knock down some of this debt
yeah you need to get some progress on it
before you even move to a rental house
but um yeah I think you're gonna it's
going to take you a while so you're
gonna have to live somewhat of a life
but you know you don't need to plan on
vacations and you don't need to plan on
expensive car purchases or anything else
you've got a substantial mess on your
hands and you're gonna have to really
lean into it to make it go away inside
of ten years you can do it in five I
mean you have no life at all
you can do it in six and have a tiny bit
of a life okay but but it's not gonna be
buying a house and it is gonna be you
know you're having kids during that time
for sure I mean that's a long time to
put off having kids but so are either
one of you let's see he's in graphic
arts he's making sixty why are you only
making forty as a counselor that's low
no I so I work full-time as at an
insurance company I'm not fully licensed
yet so I'm provisionally licensed so I
work part-time at a crisis center so I
won't get my full salary as the
clinician it's run fully licensed which
will be about what another year you got
a year worth of practice shot about a
year at about a year and a half anywhere
from here and a half to two years I just
started at the crisis center this year
you have to get so many hours of
practicum yes sir and then your master's
allows you to pass and start yeah as a
clinician you ought to be up around a
hundred shouldn't you hopefully yeah see
that changes our numbers a little bit
once you get there as it doubles your
income takes you from one hundred one
hundred and sixty yeah you know and
household income and that that that
changes the curve so you might do this
if you know given that you might do this
in four years okay but you guys are just
gonna have to be very intentional and
you know I don't want you freaked out
paralyzed with fear but I want you
scared enough I want you scared enough
to stay on task
okay you know I health II kind of affair
like don't touch the hot stove kind of
fear right okay not I'm overwhelmed I'll
never get out of this and I'm hopeless
not that that's not you got to fight
through so but but you can do it I can
mathematically see it I just know you
got a long tough life right of you for
these next couple years okay and quick
as you can get that practicum under your
belt and double your income the faster
you do that the faster this mess has
gone and the faster you move on past it
right yes sir so that gives you a whole
nother reason to crank up those hours to
get because it's a number of hours and
most states is it in North Carolina yes
it is we need 1500 before we can be
clinic up north can be fully licensed
yeah and so I'm working I'm working that
like it's my overtime job because it
gets me towards 100k income away from my
40 okay I mean I'm gonna go in all-in on
that you know for this you know maybe we
can turn two years into twelve months if
you go bizarre crazy on that or maybe
fourteen months or something you know
instead of just going well the normal is
no normally where you are right so you
know get after it and have you guys been
through Financial Peace University I
want you to go through it because I want
the support around you for you to guys
to get dialed in on a hardcore track
that gets you out of this mess okay and
I'm gonna pay for it I'm gonna give it
to you okay thank you thank you alright
it's a nine week class you have to go
once a week for nine weeks you have to
attend if I give it to you free and then
some day when you're out of this mess
you find somebody that's scared and
overwhelm with student loan debt you pay
for them to go through but that's later
on okay you'll have plenty of
opportunities to do that as a clinician
I promise you Wow
thank you for the call hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh